on how to optimize a program and a
couple of generic methods to analyze the
conversion rate of a recursive data log
or the logo program
and now we're going to switch gears a
little bit uh it's still actually on the
same theme of recurs recursive query
evaluation like reachability is
transitive closure right it says you
know we are using slightly different
language and so I'm delighted to
introduce Carl bringman from The Max
Planck Institute who is going to give us
an overview of this topic from the fine
grain complexity perspective
all right thanks for the introduction
can everybody hear me
uh okay so what's this talk about
so
I got this invitation from from hung
that I should talk about recursive query
evaluation and I didn't know what this
term is supposed to mean
so I asked what kind of queries he's
thinking about and he told me about like
visibility problems in graphs distance
problems and graphs okay so I can talk
about that it's not really a concept in
algorithms I would say there's nobody
would who would say I work on recursive
graph algorithms
but there are
reachability problems there are distance
problems so
um yeah let me also mentioned that this
is a huge area inside algorithmics so
what I will present is a very personal
View
and there are also many more experts
that are probably much more experts than
me on this topic attending this program
with Virginia and URI and Andrea and
lots of others and also the other
program like Michael and lots of other
people so talk to them if you want to
know more
um my databases are graphs graphs come
in lots of different variants undirected
directed rated unweighted and so on
sometimes there are more variants in the
details like how you encode weights I
will talk about this a bit later whether
there are negative cycles for your
distance problems and so on so there are
other types of graphs or
ways to differentiate graphs
[Music]
typical parameters are the number of
nodes and number of edges but there can
be others like the output size of a
problem or taken into consideration the
range of your weights or other things
will also come into play later
that's my input
and on this type of input I want to
solve which ability problems it's the
most basic reachability problem is that
you have a single node you want to know
what other nodes are reachable from that
we all know how to solve that I hope at
least all the algorithms people know
that you just run DFS or BFS from this
Source node and then in denial time you
find out all the reachable notes
uh
right now
um so let's go to more interesting
problems uh
if single source is easy then we try to
show that how to solve the old pairs
version right so I want to know for any
pair of nodes whether you can retrieve
in undirected graphs that's again very
simple and again we all know how to do
this and we have to compute the
connected components of the graph here's
one connecting component here's another
connected component and basically by
running DFS again one can solve this in
linear time and explore the whenever we
start a DFS you explore one connected
component and then if you have any other
unexplored node you run DFS again and
just only take linear time
graphs again is very simple very boring
a very classic solution
uh on directed graphs the problem
becomes interesting
so there we typically talk about that
Computing the transitive closure of a
graph right so here it would be this is
our input graph we want to compute all
these additional dotted edges here
because for example five can reach 7 via
this path so we want to add this edge
here to the transitive closure so the
bolt edges together with the dotted
edges would be the output
um
one very easy and easy thing that we can
do is just run single cell switch
ability from every node so we get time n
times M from every of the N possible
start notes we need linear time in the
number of edges to compute the
reachables It's Time and Time them
and now let me be let me take a
simplistic view in this talk and try to
analyze everything just in terms of one
parameter right just take the number of
edges as my parameter then I can upper
bound n times M by m squared right
um so assuming that there are no
isolated notes let me do that
uh and that running time is also kind of
optimal right because there are graphs
where that have like a linear number of
edges and a quadratic number of
reachable pairs if you think of a star
where everything here is connected to
the middle node and the middle notes
connects to everything here then you get
a quadratic number of uh of of reachable
pairs in the output so the output size
can be up to M squared large so in terms
of this parameter M squared is also an
optimal running time just because the
output size can be large
order then forces information but in a
more compact
but
it's not the right number of possible
options
uh depends on what exactly we think of
the what should the output be right but
let me also be simplistic here in this
sense and just say the output should be
or the all the edges then then this is
all right
now the other important parameter is the
number of nodes n
if you bound the right time n times n in
terms of n then it's n cubed right
because the number of edges can be up
down squared uh this is not really
optimal because in fact turns out that
the problem is equivalent to Boolean
matrix multiplication please
so the output size can be
Omega n square right because you are for
every pair of nodes so also I mean there
are graphs where you get M squared many
output edges those are sparse graphs but
if you if I only want to look at M as my
only parameter ignore n
then well in sparse graphs where m is
equal to n I can get up to M square at
many reachable reachable pairs so this
is really the view of only looking at
the parameter M ignore n completely
then this is a tight Bound in terms of
Bandits
now in the next slide I completely
ignore the number of edges I only look
at the number of notes then n cubed is
the only possible upper bound that I can
give on this running time here right
but it's not the optimal time known for
this problem because as I said the
problem is equivalent to Boolean matrix
multiplication
which is shown here so what we're going
to compute is the transitive closure of
an endnote graph and what I'm claiming
is that first of all there's the
reduction from this two Boolean mates
multiplication so if you can solve
Boolean match notification fast you can
also solve Transit closure fast
and the reduction is this free line
thing here you write down your adjacency
Matrix plus you add self-loops for every
node
and then login times you square the
adjacent symmetries we're using this
Boolean Matrix bucket
uh
right so in the I step basically you you
detect all the pairs of nodes that are
within distance 2 to the I
so you already know all the paths within
distance 2 to the I if you square the
Matrix and you find all the paths within
distance to the I plus one if you do
this login times you find everything
within distance n and nothing is further
than n away from each other
uh good they are just login Boolean
Matrix products here Boolean matrix
product we can compute in time and to
the maker so with just one more lock
factor which I'm hiding in this hotel
annotation and we can compute the
transitive structure okay what is Omega
well let's just say it's defined as the
optimal exponent of boolean's
multiplication or Microsoft replication
and not going to make a difference here
so then this this is the running time
that comes out
uh I said that his equivalent and really
there's also a very simple reduction the
other way around which is this so if you
want to compute a Boolean matrix product
then you can write down this graph here
a three-layered graph which encodes The
Matrix a and between the left and the
middle notes and the code encodes Matrix
B between middle and right notes
and then if you compute the transitive
closure of this that means if in
particular we find out for every node on
the left and every node on the right
whether they are connected
then turns out that this transitive
closure is actually
the Boolean product of the two
right
in terms of closure means there is the
path of length 2 here and that's the
same as saying that the the output entry
one comma 8 is true in this Boolean
product
so from the Computing the transit
closure of this graph then you can read
off what is the Boolean product
and that means that Computing a
transitive closure of a graph is at
least as hard as Computing a Boolean
product
in particular these problems are
equivalent
equivalent up to lock factors that's
what I've shown actually something
stronger is known that they're even
equivalent up to constant factors but
let me ignore that here so in particular
if well if we Define omega as the best
possible running time of Boolean
multiplication then transitive closures
has the same running time after lock
factors
um
good so now we know what is the optimal
running time for uh for transitive
closure namely it's enter the Omega and
well we don't really know what Omega is
but the exponent of Boolean methods
multiplication
um
right so far so good so now we
understand the problem in terms of N and
M uh the database folks as far as I know
are also very much interested in output
size so let's look at that as a
parameter
um
I can do the same equivalence
looking at the output size as the
parameter
same equivalence meaning yeah exactly
the same code as I had before
um
right what does it mean it means that in
order to solve the transitive closure
I'm doing login Boolean Matrix products
and every intermediate Boolean matrix
product will be matrices that are like
subsets of the final transitive closure
so the intermediate input size is at
most the size of the final transitive
closure and also the product that I
compute is a subset of the final
transitive closure so also the
intermediate output size will be at most
the final size of the transitive closure
it means every Boolean matrix product
that I need to do in order to find the
transitive closure and both input and
output size can be bounded by the size
of the transitive clutch
okay so that means I want to have a an
algorithm for bmm that is fast in terms
of the input and output size if I can
solve b m in time input plus output size
to some constant C it means I obtain an
algorithm for transitive closure in time
output size so size of the transitive
closure to
again it's an equivalence
and the one you can do the other with
only a lock Spectrum excuse me if the
input is bounded from a bus by the
output right to you then write it in the
Big O notation yeah so
I mean is there a reason or is it really
it's not incorrect I just want to ask
maybe there's some
it would be I mean alternatively I would
need to write like a second condition
that the input sizes at most output size
uh I didn't want to write this condition
so instead I say you want to be faster
than the sum of the two okay
all right okay
is there anything a little more
sensitive in the sense that you could
think about like input
for for transitive closure though we
don't need that we did this is exactly
the things we want for transitive
closure
yeah but I will talk about later
okay so we want to solve transitive
closure we found out that actually we
need to solve this sparse setting of
Boolean mats product where we have some
bound on the input size so meaning
number of non-zeros and the input we
have some Bond on the output size I want
to be fast in terms of these two
parameters
uh Boolean matrix product is widely
studied also very sparse settings not so
much though the version with bounded
output size so the only results that I'm
aware of that actually have a Bound in
terms of the output size are as follows
so oh actually the first thing is like
what is the like trivial lower Bound for
this kind of problem
[Music]
um
well certainly if you can solve
yeah you can solve uh Spartan bmm and
this time then just by using the upper
bound that the input size is at most N
squared and the output sizes at most N
squared you can also solve
the like this dense case of bmm In Time
into the 2C
so that means C should be at least Omega
half
otherwise we get a faster algorithm for
the standard setting of bmm and with the
current bound of Omega that means the
exponent has to be roughly at least this
uh some people also like to think about
the setting with Omega S2 and then this
would not be any contrival one
um
good so the only algorithms that I'm
aware of that have specific bounds in
terms of the output size are first of
all it is and Ryan Williams and Woodruff
and Zhang and they show an exponent of
1.5 and it's a combinatorial algorithm
it's not using fast much multiplication
so it doesn't depend on the value of
Omega
uh and then Amazon and pay they showed
that one can get the the triangle
detection time two Omega weight Omega
plus one that's about 1.41 with the
current bounce that's the exponent of
triangle detection and they showed that
one can get this exponent also for the
sparse setting of BMN
and what we recently did or recently put
an archive with uh together with Amir he
was here and Nick Fisher and Marvin
Goodman we improved this exponent to
uh well with the current Omega it's
1.3459 if Omega has two would I mean it
doesn't beat the state of the heart and
it would again still be a four-thirds
with current Omega there's an
improvement the precise bound depends on
mu which is one of the constants related
to Medicine multiplication and namely
this one here if you're interested in
it's we it's known relatively precisely
that mu is roughly 0.5
um anyways
um
so kind of the surprising thing here is
that uh it turns out to be simpler than
triangle detection for triangle
detection we do not know how to solve it
in this running time for this output
sensitive or fully sparse bmm we know
how to do it
um
yeah kind of the difference is that in
Triangle detection you want to multiply
two of The Edge sets and then check for
every edge here whether it was a one in
the product
but the product can be very large right
there can be many pairs connected by two
parts and we're only interested in very
few uh
outputs of this product
and it turns out to be a more difficult
setting than if you say if you already
have a guarantee that not too many pairs
are connected by a tube
may also mentioned that this is
deterministic for bmm we can generalize
it for two integers even for integers
with positive and negative entries
meaning there can be cancellations
meaning the output size can be smaller
than you would expect because of
cancellations even then we can get the
same running time but then we'll be
randomized
that's the next slide
excellent okay now the one after it
um
first let me ask whether further
improvements are possible and so in the
same work we also show The Following
equivalence namely that if you want to
improve upon our algorithm if you want
to get a exponent less than what we get
here
then you need to do exactly the
following thing you need to solve and
all that just trying a problem in some
fast running time what is this problem
it's a problem where you're given a
graph with a trap attack graph with
endnote 0 and nodes here enter the MU
nodes there
remember mu is about 0.5 so that's
roughly root n nodes in this part
and we also get an upper bound that
there are not too many edges between
these two big Parts only into the
OnePlus new so roughly n root n edges
between the big parts
and then for for any Edge down here we
want to know is it in a triangle or not
so there's one output bit for every for
every Edge down there is it in a
triangle or not
um
in that example I mean it turns out to
be an example where like if you
enumerate two paths you get roughly this
running time if you run matrix
multiplication you also get reference
running time so basically all the
approaches that we know how to solve
this kind of problem lead to this
specific running time one n to the one
plus two mu on this kind of instance
and if you improve on this instance this
running time then you will also get a
better output and fully sparse b m
uh it's it's an equivalent so yeah
yeah it's not really a conditioner lower
bound uh because well there's no
hypothesis stating that this kind of
instance of all its strangles hard we
don't know how to base this hardness on
anything
um but at least it uh it kind of
simplifies the problem in a sense that
here there's no bound on the output size
or anything right all of these edges
could be here so I kind of have a dense
output so it kind of simplifies the
problem and you know you only need to
solve this simple problem to get it
faster
now comes the answer to hung's question
and Paris question namely uh well why
would we want exactly this input plus
output size to some constant well not
necessarily I mean we do want exactly
this for the transitive closure but in
general the problem is interesting for
any other relation right so
let's suppose that the output size is
roughly the input size to the r for some
constant r and actually this Arc could
be anywhere between 0 and 2.
[Music]
um
and then we can draw the running times
of algorithms in terms of this R so here
is R meaning uh at the very left the
output size is super small compared to
the input size at the very right the
output size is super large
and here's the the running time
complexity
and I guess the green region is well you
at least need to read the input so you
at least get exponent one you also it
needs at least need to read the write
the output so that gives an N to the r
lower bound or an r lower bound here
and I don't know this is the two is some
trivial upper bound so the green region
is where reasonable algorithms live in
and then this
input size times square root of output
size so it's the black line and that
does not use first match multiplication
and Amazon and pay they improve this to
this blue line which is kind of hard to
describe but uh yeah and we got it to
this red line here which well it's
basically always a little bit lower
this here is the like one type of bound
on our running time
uh that describes this the the solid
black line we actually can improve it a
little bit further to the to the dotted
uh red line but yeah
it's not so easy to make sense of what
this is at a particular point but um uh
let me uh point you to one interesting
Factor namely that we do get near linear
time and the output size if the output
is large enough
um so if you if you if you want to view
this result in a very coarsely and then
for example one can bound our running
time by this by the input size to
something less than two plus linear
linear output size
first algorithm that I'm aware of that
gets this like nearly near and the
output size plus sub quadratic in the
input size
it's the next slide
yeah so the dotted line is we take a
table of bounds on certain matrix
multiplication exponents like
rectangular mates multiplication
exponents there's like a table of uh for
the different bounds for certain
settings of
the dimension of the matrices and then
we put this into an LP to that produces
us a bound on our running time
and and what what comes out numerically
of this LP is this dotted line and what
we can prove easily analytically is this
is the solid line so it's a it's a
different world in the same algorithm
the picture simplifies if you assume
Omega is too then we simply get this
this Improvement here uh
particular if you just want to say it in
in this forum then it's nearly a new
linear output size plus input size
and this year also like the true running
time then becomes this input size times
output size to 1 3 plus output
so since you are near linear in the
output side can you also enumerate a
small delay or something like that
actually we discussed this yesterday and
at least I don't see how to do it but it
would be super interesting to get that
yeah
does your algorithm needs to know the
out or have a calcium approximation of
the out
yes it does not need to know out here no
need to not need to know
all right that's the answer to Hans
question
um very course overview of what this
algorithm is doing and so let's suppose
this a matrix system engines x times Y
and the B Matrix system engine y times z
um then the first step is that we do is
to densify the output so we use certain
hashing tricks some people would call
this sparse recovery to reduce the outer
Dimensions so that the product of the
outer Dimensions just becomes linear in
the in the output size
um
ask me about this later I'm not going to
talk about this now it's it has been
used for this type of problem before
and then Second Step once the once the
outer dimensions are small we basically
follow the kind of standard High degree
low degree argument that we split the
middle notes into high degree nodes and
low degree nodes
and then low degree nodes we can easily
enumerate all two parts so choose any
input Edge choose any of the Delta
outgoing edges of a low degree node then
your numerate all two parts
and therefore also enumerate all pairs
of endpoints that are connected
and then High degree we do match
multiplication right next multiplication
meaning
um for the middle notes we only use the
high degree notes among y now so we get
some kind of Interest multiplication of
this form
we have to bound what is the complexity
of this medicine application
uh we use two bones so first of all we
use the the uh that we densified the
output meaning that Z can be at most out
of X and then we use that or the or the
Y is a high degree meaning we have can
have at most input size over Delta many
high degrees
okay
and X also cannot be too small or too
large basically because if you want to
have in many edges between these two you
cannot have less than Delta nodes here
okay so that is the complexity of this
part
basically the one important new thing
that would show is that you can bound
this by the most imbalanced of these
terms
uh so that you can just plug in the
smallest possible X you get an upper
bound on this running time for any
possible X
uh it makes sense intuitively because
matrix multiplication is harder if the
matrices are more imbalanced
proving this means that we actually have
to open up the tensor decomposition
framework of much notification and prove
some some relations on on tensor rigs
all right and now we get two terms in
our running time like the two path thing
and the medicine application thing now
we just need to balance these two terms
by plugging in the right Delta using
upper boundaries multiplication to to do
this and it turns out that if input size
and output size are the same then what
you get by balancing this is exactly the
expression for for this new constants of
medicinal application
um
it's a very big overview as I said
how
the implementations
you take a simple exponent like
classroom which of these into the things
that are close to being implemented
different steps different
implementation
yeah so let me actually first mention
that um all of these steps have been
used before like this this High degree
low degree is super standard like
basically all of the algorithms are
doing that uh the densification hashing
suppose recovery has also been used not
exactly in the same way as we're using
it but has also been used for certain
types of smart notification so
in theory or at least I'm only aware of
in theory
can't really say that it has been used
in fact this
um
so so like the algorithmic ingredients
here are not new the the uh not really
at least the like the main new thing is
that we get tight upper bounds on the
running time of this
did I say this correctly
yeah
yeah so okay so that was the the uh that
was this was the disclaimer that whether
this is I mean uh
there was a disclaimer because I mean
this algorithmic ingredients and have
they have been used before so I would
expect that they have been also been
tried out in practice but I don't really
know
um
whether this is practical the sparse
recovery definitely is used in other
areas I haven't I don't know whether
it's being used from its multiplication
I mean I'm not an expert on the
Practical side of this
uh this year is super simple and
definitely is being used whether you
should use 10 smart certification at
some point whether it makes sense to use
stressing at some point here
I don't know I don't I'm not aware of
any practical work on this
uh does this General rise to a chain of
matrices if you have three or four
um
only in the sense that well the the
input size of the second product would
be the output size of the first product
at least we don't have any better bonds
than this right now but it would be
interesting to look at it yeah
so when you actually have a paper in
Signal three years ago we implemented
this thing is
so there was a follow-up paper so it is
it is it really works but you don't use
trash and you use just a library of fast
electrification and they do
vectorization this kind of Click so it's
it's much faster but you still do you
actually use your Hardware to do fast
then it's magnification not your
algorithmic into
it let's start what I would expect
one of the like
one of the philosophical perspectives on
Facebook multiplication is that it makes
sense to design algorithms that use fast
mode certification because there are
circuits doing it fast or fast
implementations doing it right
one thing is that modern ships like I
don't know I'm not sure whether this
thing has it already but they they
Implement on the CPU they have special
circuits just for much notification
right just for uh I'm not sure what is
the current size something like 20 by 20
image notification you have a specific
part of your chip dedicated to that so
uh so you can just speed up any density
multiplication by repeatedly calling
this part of your of your CPU
so so there is Hardware acceleration
format notification it's not it won't
give the same running time as treason
but it will give some speed up for
density notification which you can then
use in this dense particle
because real matrix multiplication
in the chief system over the real things
yeah and flowing point but yeah
so this output stands densification is
not a crucial
steps
here it's crucial to get our bonds
are you going to show us the output
identification
um
yeah I mean I talked about all this
stuff
um
this year was the important part of it
you started talking about reachability
questions or transitive closure uh how
this works with thermometer n and M if
you talk about the parameter being the
output size then the best that we know
now is output size to the 1.3459
and we don't really know what is the
optimal exponent
with the techniques that we are aware of
like four thirds actually is
the barrier
um and this is very close to four thirds
but uh but we don't have like a nice
conditional lower bound or anything
good then I can talk a little bit about
distance problems in graphs
um
we talk about distances then we need
Edge weights or Edge lengths so every
eight every Edge should come equipped
with the weight and we somehow need to
also encode these weights and there are
actually lots of different uh models how
to do that in algorithms
so generally I'm assuming the ram model
here meaning every Edge rate fits into a
cell of my machine uh maybe a constant
number of cells I don't care and
arithmetic operations on two machine
cells can be done in constant time
but even then
um I mean we can talk about integer
weights meaning integers in between some
minus W and w
[Music]
um
and even if we say integer weights and
there are different regimes of how large
these these integers are so if these
weights are near constant then we can
afford W factors in the running time
totally fine with that if the weights
become larger say polynomial and n and
we don't really want a w effector in a
running time but the locked away factor
is totally fine it's even so fine that
we can hide it in our hotel the notation
that we typically use in algorithms
um
once these weights become let's say
slightly super polynomial then we we are
still fine with log W factors but we
don't want to hide it in notella because
it's a bit more than log n
and uh and when the weights become so
large that we don't even want locked
away factors then typically we want a
strongly polynomial algorithm meaning an
algorithm whose running time is
independent of w
how can that make sense well I'm still
assuming that I can do arithmetic
operations on machine cells in constant
time so you can operate on log W bits in
constant time basically
but I wanted the number of arithmetic
operations as independent of of the
actual numbers that's that's a strongly
polynomial
and all of them make sense depending on
well how your input looks like
um of course not everything is in
Detroit so you can also we can also look
at real weights and then you can either
think of really a real Ram machine where
you can store real numbers in machine
cells and you can do arithmetic
arithmetic operations on Wheels in
constant time or you can think of really
floating Point approximation so
um so that would mean that your input
already comes in floating point you you
calculate with proton Point numbers it
also means that the output you will most
likely only be able to produce an
approximation of the result
and then the different implementations
of this floating Point different
assumptions on how many bits there are
in the Mentos and exponent and so
all of these are being used in
algorithms papers
all of them have their justification in
certain settings
so um
I guess the the two models that I see
most are these two and the one that I
will be focusing on in this talk is this
one so I will make locked away factors
explicit
um so I guess the the takeaway here is
that first of all algorithms people they
should specify in their papers what of
these models they use and the database
people they should take care in checking
like what are the assumptions of
algorithms that they're using
and some sometimes is only visible in
the fine print of the papers
all right
um
again
easiest problem the easiest distance
problem is a single shortest path right
given a source node compute all
distances to other nodes
and that's very classic we know how to
do that right it's non-negative Edge
rates here and dijkstra's algorithms
actually what do we actually know how to
do it well for General Edge rate it's
not really right uh there's this classic
German Ford algorithm that computes
uh shortest paths in graphs of Negative
Edge rates in MN time
and then
people develop the scaling based
approach where you do somehow log W
rounds of something I looked over your
rounds of getting closer and closer to
the two distances
um so then the running time actually
depends on the range of the of the
integers
and this was developed in the 80s and
90s to be roughly time M root n and then
there was this recent Breakthrough by
Aaron Bernstein who is I think an
organizer of the other program right and
then work Nissan and they got the best
paper award last year at Fox to get rid
of this root n factor and get really
near linear in m and and one left of the
effect
it's still a scaling based algorithm it
still has this log W but other than that
it's near linear and the number of edges
and we've further improved this recently
and so this set about nine log factors
so we brought it down to about three log
factors which I guess is still not super
practical but uh well getting closer
um
right so for distances already single
Source version is interesting uh
actually the big open problem here is
whether it's log double you can be
removed
I get a strongly polynomial algorithm
that is near linear infinite proficiency
and then of course we can also talk
about all pairs again
um
surprisingly like the we got odd it had
all this headache for the single Source
version with negative edges for all
pairs you can just get rid of negative
edges it's a general purpose reduction
that
transforms a graph with Negative Edge
rates to one without Negative Edge rates
and it runs an NM time it's unknown
um
okay so how fast can we solve all pairs
before this path then well certainly you
can run dixtra from every node just as
we did for all pairs readability right
one eligibility algorithm from every
node and you do this once for all of
endnotes you run a near linear time in M
by using Textra
um so that's roughly n times M time
again if we look at parameter M we could
upper bound this by m squared and again
that's kind of optimal because the
output size can be up to N squared right
output size would be or pairwise
distances which is N squared which can
be up to N squared
uh in terms of just the parameter n n
times M we can again upper bound it by n
cubed
and similarly as for transitive closure
there is an equivalence to a different
matrix product
so this time the the equivalences to Min
plus product where the I comma Jada
entry of the output is the minimum of
our K of a i k plus bkj you can compute
this kind of product
uh in whatever running time you can
compute or pass through this path in the
same running time with a log Factor more
and really the same reduction as before
it did now take the weighted adjacency
Matrix you add zero rate self loops and
then for login rounds you repeatedly
Square The Matrix using you know Min
plus product
and the same reduction in the other way
around also still works that if you want
to compute them in class product and you
can compute all passwords path you can
use
so both problems are equivalent in the
same way as before actually Virginia and
Ryan they showed that there's one more
very interesting equivalence here to
negative triangle which I don't want to
go into detail here but I guess this was
discussed in the boot camp so I don't
really have to
and this is a little bit different kind
of an equivalence like here the
equivalence is that the running times
are the same up to lock factors here the
equivalence is that if one is sub cubic
also the other sub cubic it doesn't mean
that you get the same sub cubic time but
if one is sub cubicles to the others
and then the all passwords path
hypothesis states that all of these
problems well cannot be solved and sub
cubic
okay so that means in parameter n we can
solve apsp in N Cube time and the
optimality of this is the apsp
hypothesis so we don't know whether this
is true but it's one of the central
hypothesis
and we also mentioned that the Brian was
able to save off these log factors here
or modern lock factors to the root log n
but it's not n to the 2.99 times so this
is the fastest known algorithm in theory
for a PSP
okay
um
now
yes
so in terms of M
M
I guess the heart message but let's say
the both of the matrices are very smart
I'm in the same as here I guess
that's the best like
again it's just like if you're the
star-like thing that can be M squared
outputs
good
um
now for transitive closure we talked
about the output size for apsp that
doesn't really make sense right the
output size is always N squared you want
to know all the N squared distances
um so that relaxation doesn't really
make sense here instead it now makes
sense to talk about approximation
algorithms right this is kind of the
first place where it makes sense to talk
about approximation algorithms right
reachability you cannot approximate
single Source distances we said there
are anyways in near linear time so you
don't need to approximate them uh apsp
is really the first problem in this talk
here where it makes sense to talk about
approximation now we want to approximate
all pairwise distances
I was how hard is that
so um turns out that there is a
reduction from Boolean matrix
multiplication
uh which is again the usual reduction
that you want to multiply two Boolean
matrices A and B and you write them down
as a three layered Network like this
then if you compute if you even just
approximate distances from left nodes to
right nodes then you know whether they
are connected right because
if they are connected if there is a one
in their output for from two to seven
that means the true distance is two
they're not connected to two distance is
infinite so if you get any kind of
approximation of the distances you can
distinguish two from infinite so
in particular you know
so at least as hard as exact P members
approximating apsp is at least it's
hardest exactly
Nettles indirected graphs if you get a
good enough approximation a better than
two approximation it also holds an
undirected graphs really because if they
are connected the two distances two if
not then the true distance is at least
four
so if you can distinguish two from four
if you get a better than two
approximation then it's uh you also need
to be able to compute a Boolean matrix
product to get the scan for
approximation
okay so enter the Omega kinda is lower
Bound for
um
so we can
first question now of course is can we
get entered the Omega and that is what
we did some time ago that um one can one
plus Epsilon approximate or pair with
distances in this running time here so
this is really entod Omega there are
some dependence on Epsilon but let's say
you want a constant Factor then Epsilon
is really just a constant and there is a
log W here
right so this matches this lower bound
here
um one can actually argue that there's
there has to be some polynomial
dependence on Epsilon
I mean under some version of the apsp
hypothesis
[Music]
hi let me also mention that this is
again follows from the same kind of
equivalence as we have seen before that
approximating apsp is equivalent up to
log factors to an appropriate matrix
product and in this case the appropriate
matrix product is some approximate
version of main Plus convolution
thank you
[Music]
um
of course now can ask is this lock
Factor necessary or can we have a
strongly polynomial primary algorithm
and it's what we answered some time ago
that in undirected graphs this is
actually possible one can shave off this
log W and replace it by logands
um
so there one can shave off shave this
off and directed graphs it's not really
possible uh turns out that well you can
get rid of the log w at the at the cost
of
worsening this exponent to 3 plus Omega
half
and this is also kind of necessary
because
approximating apsp in directed graph
turns out to be equivalent to exactly
solving the min max product of two
matrices and for this problem the best
that we know as this handful
so again there's some equivalence to an
appropriate matrix product that tells
you the answer
good so this is I mean we saw this into
the Omega lower bound if you want into
the Omega or close to it then those are
the results
uh now there's one case where that could
allow you to be better than n to the
Omega you're right namely on undirected
graphs and you want a two
approximational works
is not excluded here right so let's
focus on this now and namely that we
want just some constant Factor
approximation in undirected graphs
that also turns out to be possible uh
URI and mikkel so at some point also a
long time ago by now
um that one can take an undirected graph
and pre-process pre-process it in this
time here so what is K here you can fix
any constant K actually can be even
super constantly be focused on the
constant case so you can fix any
constant k and you can pre-process your
graph in this well almost linear time
right M times n to the one over K if I
choose my K to be 100 then this is very
close to linear time
and then after this so This
pre-processing build some data structure
such that I can then give two nodes u
and v to this data structure and the
data structure tells me uh a constant
Factor approximation to the distance
from U to V namely 2K minus 1
approximation
and the data structures the query is
also super fast like this answers this
in constant time
right so this this tells us like that we
can avoid this into the Omega if we are
an undirected graphs and our
approximation ratio is some large
constant
uh and what we did recently is the is to
show a kind of a matching condition a
lower bound down nearly matching
conditional lower bound namely if you
assume the three sum conjecture and you
allow the same kind of repossessing Time
Is Here and you can we can even relax
the query time to be login or poly login
or any any subpolynomial function n and
a little F1 even with some relaxed query
time one cannot compute a better than K
approximation
they are still a factor two missing here
and that's that that Gap Still Remains
but at least kind of qualitatively this
the same this result is also tight
and this was shown with Amir who is here
and Siri who is here and or and Nick and
there was this first paper here which
said kind of worst bounds and then the
second paper has better bounds and
independently the same bounds were also
shown by su and uh sorry
yes
[Music]
um
right and this like this is kind of one
example of a hardness of approximation
in P result what does it mean it means
that uh well we
have some problem that can be solved in
polynomial time but exactly it's kind of
costly so you relax to just approximate
this polynomial time problem
um but then you can still maybe not
solve it in the linear time and you want
to still prove some fine grained lower
bound just for approximating this
polynomial time problem
and this is possible for some problems
like this is one example turns out to be
super hard because I mean you not only
need to be
fine Grant enough not to lose any
factors in the running time you also
need hardness of approximation
techniques combining that turns out to
be a very difficult
um
some cool results
okay
coming to the end
um
so I mean I try to give like a
survey-ish intro to reachability and
distance problems and graphs right turns
out at least for the problems that I
looked up here this this the the single
Source variants they are all very simple
right they can be soft in near linear
time
or pairs variants turn out to be not so
simple
but they're also equivalent that they're
all equivalent to some appropriate
matrix product always turns out that you
want to solve some
distance or reachability problem up to
lock factors is equivalent to some
appropriate matrix product
maybe this is one reason why recursive
queries are not really a thing in
algorithms because they are all actually
equivalent to non-recursive Curves
um
of course there are more many more
directions here that I did not discuss
at all I think the boot camp kind of
covered a little bit these centrality
measures of diameter radius girth and so
on
um instead of multiplicative
approximation they are very interesting
additive approximations for apsp there's
the setting of near constant weights
that is
also interesting I didn't talk about it
at all
um
you can look at then these problems on
dynamic graphs you can look at failing
edges you want to find the shortest path
after one Edge fails spanners what not
it's a huge and active research area and
as I said there are lots of people here
that you can talk to if you want to know
more that's it for me
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]